picture this driverless cars that can
connect to each other online health
monitoring intuitive eServices virtual
reality and self adjusting appliances
the fridge will always be cold enough
the heater warm enough the TV bright
enough data can also be sent from these
machines to service provider welcome to
the world that 5th generation mobile
networks all 5g attack buzzword that
could soon be the norm in business and
in daily life the EU is gearing up to
usher in this high-speed high-capacity
digital world by 2025 with 700 million
euros that aside for it plus private
sector funding it's changing everything
it opens new possibilities in the
industry it's opening technology in many
services
[Music]
there's a lot of work ahead
infrastructure regulations and products
have to be updated security concerns
over increased connectivity have to be
addressed and there's the digital divide
any peas are calling for universal
access to technology to ensure that this
5g digital future is a future for all